القريبه من هنا للغايه عادل ما زالت تشهد
الاشتباكات المستمره قوات فاجنار في مقابل
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تقول القياده
العسكريه هنا انها من افضل القوات التي
تشارك في هذه الجبهه بصفه عامه عادل
القوات التي قوات الاوكرانيه في الجبهه
الشرقيه هي افضل القوات بالفعل التي تشارك
في الحرب خاصه وانها تشارك في هذه الحروب
مع الانفصاليين وبعد ذلك القوات الروسيه
منذ سنوات منذ عامه 2014
في قتال في هذه المنطقه هناك محاولات
مستمره للتقدم وتطويق القوات الاوكرانيه
من قبل الجانب الروسيه والقوات الروسيه
لكن هذه المحاولات لم تنجح حتى الان وفقا
لقياده الاركان الاوكرانيه التي تقول انها
مستعده لشن هجوم مضاد وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه يقول ان نحن على استعداد الان
لشن هجوم مضاد في وقت قريب في الماضي كانت
اوكرانيا لا يسمح لها بالحصول على اسلحه
قويه لكن الامور قد تغيرت الان وباتت
اوروبا تعرف ان اوكرانيا تدافع عن كامل
الاراضي الاوروبيه لذلك وصول الاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه خلال فتره قصيره سيسمح
لاوكرانيا بالقيام بالهجوم المضاده اذا
نجحت القوات الروسيه في السيطره على مخموس
سيكون الطريق مفتوحا الى كراماتوس التي
نقف فيها الان وكذلك سفيانسك القريبه من
هذه المنطقه بخ موت بالنسبه للقوات
الروسيه هي البوابه شبه الوحيده التي
سيطره تماما على وبما اننا نقف في الجانب
الاوكراني من دونيسكو الذي سيطر على
القوات الاوكرانيه هناك تخوف شديد من قبل
المواطنين هنا مع قدوم فصل الربيع وتحسن
الاجواء ابن ان يقوم الروس بشن هجوم قوي
مدعومه بالطبع بالطائرات يعني سترى على
هذه المدينه والمقاطعه بصوره كامله لكن
تاكيد بص وره مستمره من قبل القياده
العسكريه والسياسيه هنا في اوكرانيا ان
هذا لن يحدث على الاطلاق